enrique perdomo tuvo que evacuar su casa
ahora descubre la magnitud de los daños
parte del techo voló y su familia lo
reparo con una bolsa en el interior la
lluvia se filtró
aun cuando todavía intento entender lo
que me pasó
va a ser duro
y no va a ser fácil pero vamos a salir
adelante con él en la ciudad uno de cada
diez tejados está dañado su vecino
roberto robledo de 75 años se quedó
durante el paso del huracán
hacia como el ruido de un tren enorme o
hacía realmente el ruido de un viejo
motor de tren y de un momento a otro lo
entendí y todas las cejas salieron
volando en houma donde los vientos
alcanzaron 200 kilómetros por hora casi
todos los edificios están dañados
después de 48 horas new orleans sigue
sin electricidad por eso la población se
retira y toma por asalto las pocas
gasolineras abiertas que se ven nos
dijeron que no habría electricidad
durante las próximas tres semanas y aquí
en medio de este calor y sin
electricidad no podemos vivir así
no podemos ni siquiera salir de la
ciudad si queremos porque no tenemos
combustible hay personas que han
comenzado a pelearse la gasolina ahora
había un hombre que se hizo matar
necesitamos combustible comida vivienda
y aire acondicionado en los próximos
días la temperatura aumentará
convirtiendo una situación que ya es
dramática en una potencialmente
exclusiva